[BEEPS]
[GAME SOUND EFFECTS]
LILIANA YU: Ryan
Shatford, previously
the front-end and edge site
reliability engineer at Uber,
had this to say
about Stackdriver.
"Stackdriver is a
quick and easy utility
to monitor your
app's performance.
Within minutes,
we had dashboarbs
for compute instances
and VPN statistics.
An easy to use
policy based alert
management system helps us
notify on-call engineers
of issues quickly."
We're happy you like it, Ryan.
So do we.
Google Stackdriver provides
powerful monitoring, logging,
and diagnostics.
It equips you with insight
into the health, performance,
and availability of
Cloud-powered applications,
enabling you to find
and fix issues faster.
It is natively integrated with
Google Cloud Platform, Amazon
Web Services, and popular
open source packages.
Stackdriver provides a wide
variety of metrics, dashboards,
alerting, log management,
reporting, and tracing
capabilities.
This hands-on Qwiklab will
lead you through creating a VM,
installing Apache 2 on it.
And it will show you how
to create an uptime check
on Stackdriver, create
an alerting policy
for your uptime check,
create a dashboard
and chart for a CPU
load, stop your VM
and view the incident
noticed in Stackdriver,
and view the logs for your
VM with Stackdriver Logging.
As with all our labs, you do
not need a Google Cloud Platform
account or project.
An account, project,
and associated resources
are provided to you
as part of this lab.
If you already have
your own GCP account,
don't use it for this lab.
You're one lab away from
completing your quest
and getting your badge.
In case you haven't been
following our other videos,
a quest is a series
of related labs
that form a learning
path on Qwiklabs.
Completing this quest
earns you this badge
to recognize your achievement.
The next and final
lab on your quest
is Setting Up Network
and HTTP Load Balances.
[MUSIC PLAYING]